is
[Music]
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
did you see the look on mr mcarthur's
face he didn't know what hit him that
was awesome
oh darn it there's officer james what do
we do i know let's run into that
alleyway
oh shoot it's a dead end oh go darn it
now boys have you three been up to no
good i don't know what you're talking
about officer jenkins well i've been
getting some phone calls
does mr mcarthur ring a bell all right
guys run i got this i still have my bb
gun oh timmy i'm disappointed you know
you're not supposed to aim a loaded
firearm at an office yeah what are you
gonna do about it officer jenkins i'll
tell you what i'm going to do to you
timmy first you're going to put the
loaded firearm down
i'm going to have to call your mother
but first
we'll go grab an ice cream cone and talk
about it what do you say
okay
can i ride in the front of the paddy
wagon oh jimmy
usually that's not allowed but
since you're white
oh those boys what pickle will they find
themselves in next stay tuned for next
week's installment of adventures of the
white privilege boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
that is a delicious sip
not really not all that delicious
honestly it tastes like tepid uh like
tepids or water but uh glad to be with
you because i didn't get to do this up
yesterday because we had you know had a
fireplace that wasn't going and it was a
quagmire uh
look we have a lot to get to today
um
yeah everyone's talking about twitter
everyone's talking about elon musk we'll
talk about twitter in the project
veritas the recent uh leak which is
hysterical by the way if you're um an
indian american tech engineer and a
super hot girl is asking you out on a
date
alarm bells
and asks you questions repeatedly and
asking questions repeatedly
about communism at twitter especially
when she asks for your tax return just
that's when you should go wait maybe
something's happening here so
we'll talk about that uh but we also
wanna we're doing a multi-episode arc
here because uh whenever these tragedies
happen of course what happened in uh i
mean which one do we wanna pick buffalo
but also orange county um milwaukee
milwaukee miley waukee
um
unfortunately people complain about it
getting politicized and the irony is not
lost on me that we are addressing the
politicization unfortunately we live in
a time and place in this country where
you just can't remain silent i wish we
didn't have to do this but we do and
some of this is remedial but the gun
control lies are coming out as we
predicted yesterday
there would be no doubt the left is
incredibly predictable that's why all of
our references are available at
lyderworthcrowder.com we try to arm you
so that you can be prepared with
information and there are some very
common gun control myths that have been
rearing their ugly head
uh
is it rearing or raring rearing i
thought it was rearing yeah but i used
to think it was chomping at the bit
until my friend who was camping it's
champing why is the horse championing
championing at the bit but nobody cares
yeah no it's chomping at the [ __ ] they
both should work yeah you say chomping i
do too would you correct me plus horse
girls are crazy so yeah
yeah if you have a horse i don't need
you no exactly what your dad bought you
a pony oh yeah you're the worst person
yes yes exactly when i say that you've
ever had you ever had to hang out with
horse girls all they want to talk about
is horses and they can't fathom a world
in which you do not own fifty thousand
dollar animals yeah
they brush
they brush their steed all day yes
that's all they do yep
just see this thing i brush it and ride
not to mention that matt damon films
sucked yes it did so which one all of
them well yes but was it all the pretty
horses uh the horse whisperer whichever
one where he's the one petting the horse
i think it's pretty horses yeah i just
hope that someday he walks behind one
and doesn't put his hand out like that i
saw an illegal film of the same name yes
oh
all the sticky horses yes well this was
no it was he was on a mission strip yes
it was bug
so
uh
for elmer
now we want you to be able to combat
this information uh out there and these
are not new arguments unfortunately from
the left because they have no valid
arguments actually their island is
shrinking as it relates to gun control
but they just become more vehement and
that's what you are seeing when your
arguments aren't strong you just have to
shout them more forcefully we're seeing
that from the left everything from
high-capacity magazines to once upon a
time it was tip or gore and video games
and now it's social media there's
nothing new under the sun we'll be
talking about that if we get removed
because it's one of those sensitive
topics look unless we tell you that we
are not doing a show here on youtube
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we are streaming live so we're at rumble
or mug club right where you get an extra
45 minutes today we go down the reddit
rabbit hole about a transgender
sleepover which we could never tell on
you not a chance it is hysterical and
disturbing
why because it's abnormal
the sleepover slumber party massacre
genitals yes
slumber party double mastectomy
kelvin klein it's just uh just pluto
blue tarsky with a scalpel yeah yeah
venus fight
um all right before we get to all that
and more gerald a is here how are you
sir i am well did you stumble on my name
is it i was i was about to say gerald b
ah wishful things got so used to the
thing that i killed live on air i'm well
how are you sir i'm doing okay yeah i
hurt my neck again i don't know that i
care now that you i know i don't care
just like we don't care about girls with
horses so it's okay and then he's my
dave
whoa whoa whoa you can follow him on
twitter at landau dave him and i are on
tour you can go to livestream.com tour
there are still tickets left for the
early show we added june 18th colorado
springs father's day weekend some people
call him daddy dave landau ahoy how are
you and that davey is a fan that david
is a fine i was trying to train joe
lewis to bark on commands like he's a
leader and
i don't know why i thought it would die
it's very much a dad joke
i think that's i think it's better than
a dad joke that is a vegas uh yeah
that'll get you that yeah that will get
you at the golden nuggets hopefully it
doesn't attack me like siegfried oh yeah
that's it i was trying to help him
okay so i ate his face
we have to talk about that we'll also be
talking about the new white house press
secretary ah
it's
a miracle she's worse than ginsaki well
and uh before that um
this backyard hero and we want to start
it off a little light
went hard in this next clip uh but then
we have to guess i haven't watched it
what happens next
[Music]
do not try this at home and i hope you
like it
okay so i'm supposed to guess what
happens next
what happens next is it does a dog knock
him off the table i hope so okay does he
front flip and shatter the folding table
okay or does his mom come outside and
yell at him to get a job
uh oh by the way i should ask you guys
before we do this comment below my
question i want to ask you is what do
you think uh you're gonna miss most
about former press secretary jin saki
look no one is without redeeming value
that's true so really i know you're
gonna try hard
but try uh i'm going to say
well the obvious one is he front flips
and shatters the folding table what do
you think i'm going to say his mom comes
out and yells at him to get a job yeah
uh i'm i'm a fan so i don't want it oh
you know what happened oh i know this
guy he's fantastic oh okay i love what
he's saying don't try this at home where
are you he's a juggalo he's a huge
insane clown posse fan and he goes whoop
whoop and does stunts all right i'm
going to say a dog knocks him off the
table let's go see what happens
[Laughter]
it's every video
[Music]
he has so many of these
he's going for another one
he's the best i love how he's going for
a lower one yeah usually the rule of
entertainment there's escalation yeah so
he's like i'm gonna do now i'm gonna
take a break
i'm gonna do a little bit smaller one
all right so we have to guess what
happens next token yeah what happens
next does he jump onto the printer and
break his arm oh god
uh the table he's standing on cracks and
he falls okay or does he take his pants
off well dave already knows what do you
say i'm saying pants off uh dance off
with your pants off baby i really hope
that he don't do that again i really
hope that he does not break his arm but
i'm willing to bet the way this is going
that uh that's what happened this
catchphrase is f this sf she goes
it's every
video it's the best
it's like super dave but he's really
getting hurt
mr
mr fuji is just his autistic interpreter
yeah
all right
let's uh let's see what happens next
[Laughter]
[Music]
who's he mad at nobody
yes just be upset with your own decision
he's just a juggler who does these
stunts i know someone be looking out for
him juggalo what is that dave that's an
insane clown posse fan you never heard
of a juggalo it's like a like a dead
head for the the grateful dead or
parrothead are they all like this
pretty much i mean a large portion very
it's a spectrum of juggalos there's
different ones some you know some are
cool oh there's more to it i mean this
is that was it oh no there's there's
tons of videos so if you ever want to
just watch a guy jump onto a table of
broken glass
why would you do that because it's
hilarious this is a cry for help no it's
not well look the cry for helps after he
breaks his arm on a printer
that's really more of a call for help
yeah he actually he's a place of phone
call
i i honestly felt bad for him at first
when i saw this like a couple years ago
not that this is this is a fresh one but
he's been doing this a long time but
then you realize no he really is just
this guy oh okay well that makes it
better yeah it makes it hilarious well
look that because we're going to be
talking about mass shootings and that
was a bit of a palette cleanser yeah and
he's getting sponsored by like
hewlett-packard is he really
break our princess oh the guy makes bank
off of toner ah
he goes to the er they're like oh you
again yeah oh there's no mr inkjet are
you the guy whose insurance dropped you
eight times
i wonder how that happened yeah your
deductible is iq points
uh okay speaking of iq points so now we
have a new press secretary and i gotta
tell you
i am a
karen jean-pierre fan is it kareem karen
we're gonna call her karen karine so uh
karen jean-pierre made her debut
yesterday and it was every bit as here's
the thing
i always said this about i didn't like
jen sackey but she was good at lying yes
very she was very effective very good
soulless
very good at saying circle back yes
circle back this this one
yes
not so much a lot of boxes there were
checked yes
i am obviously acutely aware
that my presence at this podium uh
represents a few firsts uh i am a black
gay immigrant woman
the first of all three of those to hold
this position i would not be here today
if it were not for generations of
barriers peop barrier breaking people
before me
i stand on their shoulders
if if it were not for generations of
very barrier-breaking people before me i
would not be here
but i benefit from their sacrifices i
have learned from their ex excellence
and i am forever grateful to them
representation does matter you hear us
you hear us say this
often in this administration and no one
understands this better than president
biden yeah no one understands diversity
better than former vice president joe
biden
the oldest white guy to have ever
achieved office if she were to go and
say i'm a i'm a gay black immigrant huh
you ain't black this is america don't
forget immigrants yes don't forget
it's good to see corbin blues getting
work
don't worry about those gas prices oh my
god she's black and gay
bye bye inflation there you go hey
speaking of inflation
she had some wise words and by that i
mean not uh on that topic too but how
does raising taxes on corporations lower
the cost of gas the cost of a used car
the cost of food for every day
so look i think we encourage those who
have done very well right especially
those who care about climate change uh
to support a fair tax code
a higher percentage of their earnings
that the most fortunate people in our
nation and not let them
stand in the way of reducing energy
costs
existential problem if you think about
that as an example no what what what
exactly collective bargaining rights as
well right that's also important but
look it is you know
by not if without having a fair tax code
which is what i'm talking about then all
every like manufacturing workers cops
you know it's not fair for them yes
you're a fan of the cops higher taxes
than the folks that who are who are who
are not paying taxes at all okay so let
me first examine that non-answer this is
when you're a classist as she is uh and
whether she believes it or not this is
what they have to sell to the american
people because they actually have sold
out the american middle class it's like
a racist where every answer is mad it's
the damn blacks or the jews every single
answer is it's rich people we need we
need to take their money yeah but how
does that help people who don't have a
lot of money and everything is costing
would you we're going to take other
people's money it's the answer to
everything here's why it doesn't work
take into account that in 2020 uh when
when you take account for a federal uh
transfers which means you know sort of
like social safety nets uh welfare
programs 60.6
of households
paid
no income tax wow
now the top 25 percent of earners
already pay 87
of all income taxes the bottom 50
percent they pay only 3
just to be clear wow
to be fair though filling the stilettos
of jen sackey was never going to be an
easy job no it was not going to be an
easy job but not a good test especially
when she was triple white that's true
thank god she checks also by the way
economists have even verified that
donald trump's tax cuts benefited the
middle class more than anybody it didn't
benefit the ultra wealthy here's the
thing the middle class are the people
who end up putting the bill i understand
what you're talking about that ultra
wealthy billionaires they put their
money offshore a lot of the time and
they don't pay a ton of taxes but we
want to we want to sort of pivot that to
capital gains that also will affect the
middle class if you're talking about
people who are retiring do you really
want to have to pay capital gains on
money that you've already paid taxes on
so they offer these solutions that
aren't solutions they just want you
to be greedy they say that it's greedy
for people to want to keep their money
but it's not greedy for you to want to
take their money regardless of how it
was earned keep in mind on the answer of
inflation only the government can create
inflation
right take that into think about this
for a second
computers are they more expensive or
less expensive smart phones now you can
get them for free generally speaking
consumer goods become more affordable as
businesses become more efficient and the
demand increases it's in the businesses
best interest to make
goods or services more affordable to
more people you can't print money
you can't create government programs you
can't tax businesses to raise the cost
of goods and services only the
government can do that
only the government can create and
exacerbate inflation
and her answer is take more money from
rich people well i think my money is
just getting pretty good yeah well
because that guy jumped on it gonna be
able to ruin the printers to buy the
jump on how many how's he gonna get the
tables one it was an incoherent answer
right she rambled on and two he asked
how is raising taxes going to fight
inflation which it won't
she didn't she didn't say it would no
she's sad
[Applause]
that's true she didn't read that it
wouldn't question at all and she didn't
answer any questions i think at all no
she didn't answer any questions well
that's her job though no her fairness
his spin her job is yeah you know what
you say you say look i understand that
inflation is high right now but by doing
x we get y right and you put your
talking points in and what she did was
ramble on about cops and saying how it's
not fair and how people do this and that
and it was incoherent and she stumbled
over every other word doing it
shitty good now maybe it's her first day
and she's got jitters because her only
qualifications were what she listed off
the top i have no idea but she didn't do
a good job of answering a question she
did do a good job though after that of
swiffering the podium now jeez
on
the uh note of gensaki uh look we always
have to honor people who we see as
worthy rivals and so jinsaki we will
miss her and it's time to we've done
this for every single candidate and
every major political figure uh jen saki
thank you for your service it's time to
close i did ask our team about this you
or someone else may have asked about
this the other day and i think i have
something on it here one moment
lots to say about kovid no doubt about
it um
[Music]
so um
[Music]
thanks for your patience
time to
[Music]
it's
close
to go to places where you go to
place yourself
see
i know that
it's time i have something
[Music]
let me let me let me um
[Music]
so
let's see
[Music]
let me let me let me um talk to our team
about it
[Music]
i'm gonna miss that soulless monster yes
i just realized the interpretation of uh
um is far longer than the word
it's just an aggravated face really well
it's her and she was awesome
honestly she looked best it was great
she's cute too yeah it's very rare that
you find a cute signer no especially
yeah especially these days especially
these days usually have hands that could
crack a crab yeah they really just open
a coconut you break it in half with
their bare hands so uh
speaking of cute
this coming sunday and this is why look
you need to protect your children okay
parents
you need to protect your kids if you put
your kids in public school at this point
it's tantamount to child abuse but also
a lot of parents think the schools will
raise their kids the school will raise
your kids the church will do your job
you cannot even rely on the church
why say even on the church you should
never rely on the church you should
never rely on the school you need to do
your job as a parent because now the
first ever youth pride conference is
going to take place
at naples united church of christ in
florida where they're going to have drag
shows so here you see it the event is
intended for
lgbtq youth
seeking to explore lgbtq related issues
uh such as
forbidden queer literature as you see
that there includes inclusive sex
education for uh four-year-olds and then
uh um political action and advocacy
because well there's your super delegate
uh they also offer a seminar on how to
navigate the challenges of becoming a
pillar of salt
yes sure uh right you might be asking
yourself how many flamethrowers should i
bring yeah
it's a struggle
mine was internal though i meant
juggling struggling flamethrowers or in
the jungle mood
and uh look come on look this is one of
those things that i know it's easy for
me to sit on my uh my high horse
that
that's champing
and uh
try and act like we didn't have some of
this when we grew up we all remember
these kinds of sermons and drag shows
when we used to go to church yeah of
course
and so the lord bestows upon us
all of us
his grace and these gifts but he tells
us the greatest
gift among them
is love
let us show our love as we continue in
worship to my favorite six-year-old max
butterbutts max
come on out here
back butterbugs
for jesus
[Music]
so the thing is we think that times have
changed but times haven't changed times
haven't changed as much as we think
no max was found dead i believe in a
hotel three weeks ago yeah i know but
that we didn't want to bring people down
right oh sorry no we wanted to show the
performance he's an adult now yeah i
don't know about this but i hope that
this church loses its tax-exempt status
yeah he's grown up he hasn't had sex in
years i don't think there should be a
write-off for seven-year-old titty
tassels
reverend how can you possibly reverend
alaskan thunder i mean it's just like
honestly this is just permeating
everywhere and this is a big
this is the thing okay it's very easy to
be mad at people who are acting exactly
as you would expect them to those on the
left but you need to hold your own
accountable if this is happening in your
church and there are just not enough
people
to simply ask
what
you need to find a new church
and that's a please
oh
oh oh god that still hurts some surgery
it's still the worst thing oh my
goodness
what's this
[Music]
i don't like this that's a little weird
i don't
know
sounds like someone's having allergy
problems well i have another problem
now who are you
i'm auntie pollen i appear when men in
their mid-30s begin yelling and cursing
when they sneeze
dude i've met this lady she's pretty
cool she's got like this spray that
makes your chews disappear it's so good
to see you again dave i hope that cute
little nose of yours is still allergy
free shut up you two time and [ __ ] well
i don't know this yeah i don't know
what's
let's keep this for after the show
what's this magical spray you have no
it's called clear oh why don't you try
something this is clear clear
where do i i put it put it in your nose
okay
there you go
hmm you know i was skeptical i was
skeptical because this is deeply
disturbing but this actually this works
really my nose isn't ticklish at all
anymore and i can breathe what's what's
this called again fentanyl
really
that's not funny guys i can die
guys people are dying from fentanyl
that's not a joke
i'm kidding it's not clear clear spell
with an axe yes because it's made with
xylitol oh clear will moisturize your
nasal passages even on your worst
allergy day well thank you thank you for
showing me the clear way auntie pollen
this is the way
hmm well thank you everyone i must run
oh wow
do you uh validate our parking not for
transgender wings no
no you can leave bye
[Music]
hmm
okay uh she's not transgender oh i don't
know i was just a hideous woman i was
fooled by the beard
thanks mr barnum
go wash your nose by the way these
people became a sponsor to the show
after i talked about how i've been using
them for a long time
during the covid you know they actually
have studies that you can go read on
their website at clearwithnext.com read
up the studies and what it does for your
nasal you think about you brush your
teeth you wash your face have any idea
what you're breathing in especially in
this studio so uh got uh it's got some
xylitol in it and it works it creates
like an antimicrobial film anyway so you
can go buy it at amazon most pharmacies
clear wonderful sponsor works really
well i just use it before i get in the
shower
and i mean my my housekeeper's not a big
fan of it but
[Laughter]
she just hasn't tried it yet so let's
like it i like it let's move on uh to
this now we're going to talk about gun
control and uh what's happened in the
wake of the shooting and a big
censorship push hey i would appreciate
it right now if you guys are watching
share just hit the share button now
youtube decides that sharing is
something awesome do we have someone
have a kleenex i'm going to need clinics
i actually spray too much of that in my
nose
that was a pretty good toss i mean come
on oh there you go see that's what
happens you you put that stuff in your
nose and clears how you're saying no it
really does you just blow it out listen
hold on guys listen
that's clear it clears out your son it
really works unintended
nasal
so um
this is of course expected in the wake
of the buffalo shooting
and uh they're they're
they're pouring on not only a hefty dose
of gun control of course but now they
want to sort of mix it up with some
white supremacy and i'm going to go
through the most common claims or the
claims that you're hearing in the media
and then give you the truth but before
you hear they'd like you to comment
below and tell me the uh
the most common gun control claims that
you hear made
for example especially if you're a
student uh or if you're in a workplace
that's particularly liberal like a
non-profit or uh that whatever was
church of christ whatever it was what
was it church it was naples church
something i don't know
church of christ of latter-day taints
yes
oh boy
ldt for short yes oh geez
just it's a joke
lds people okay it's not we're done
actually we don't think that that's your
church we know you'd never allow someone
that creepy oh yeah that's right yeah
yeah i don't think it's you guys no of
course we don't trust you guys for
crying out loud i think you're the last
people to
right really yeah it's just a jehovah's
non-testifying witnesses no it's just a
taint joke really oh so
you're welcome general thank you david
you can go to church twice this week i
will have to
gosh can you imagine showing up in
confessional and that's what's looking
through the little little uh spotted oh
lord oh my gosh you first how about some
hot gossip yeah
let's talk about the kardashians
i don't want to
no i need to confess my sins
me too
why is there a hole here
that's confessional that's what we do
was there a disco ball just to make you
comfortable are you comfortable no
what is it what's this vibrating
all right
so uh the wake of the buffalo shooting
this is in its horrible tragedy of
course it's been condemned but there
have been other shootings that have
taken place that the media really hasn't
talked about by the way called it with
orange county
a little bit chinese uh national hates
the taiwanese ah chinese government
you could have seen that coming and
specifically targeting a taiwan church i
think john cena is responsible yes so
let's uh before the bodies have assumed
room temperature you got the gun control
rhetoric with white supremacy sprinkled
in here you go this can occur anywhere
it's not just buffalo it's how to make
people
all across this country feel safe it's
not just african americans it's how to
make people in urban america suburban
america and rural america feel safe
the only way to do it is to really get
to the point of sensible gun control in
this country uh to end hate speech on uh
the internet and social media there you
go uh to stop the proliferation of
hateful ideology
those are the ways that we make
black people feel safe in buffalo that
will we make people feel safe all across
this country pivoted from uh gun control
to social media happiness is a warm
tweet now it would be really important
to mention here before we get to
anything else uh and we have a lot of
claims that we need to address
if you only remember one this is the
most recent year for fbi crime reporting
and by the way
the fbi is not even necessarily reliable
so whatever you're seeing you can take
it with a grain of salt meaning it's
probably worse uh there were 13 000
right 600 gun murders gun homicides
total there were 1.67 million defensive
uses of firearms so that's the
difference of 1.5 something million i
didn't round the one so just keep in
mind whenever someone says if it saves
one life well they're willing to take at
least a million lives
in a good year to be clear is that just
america that's just the united states
just the united states yeah 1.67
defensive uses and people think the
homicide is a lot higher than it's
thirteen thousand gun hum
yeah that's really not nearly as high as
people think no and we would love for
that number to be lower but just look at
the 1.67
million yeah you're telling those people
that they no longer have a right and by
the way i don't believe that number for
a second because there have been other
estimates
been between two and three million so
this is the fbi claiming that uh and
it's very hard to measure defensive uses
of firearms because often the gun is
never even fired
yeah oh no i was gonna tell you like
also with the white supremacy thing
gerald saw this article too and said can
you believe a day after the uh the
buffalo shooting white people were
entertained by black people by watching
basketball this was an actual article
this is an article actual article that
came out this is white supremacy is what
they said this is what white supremacy
looks like people watching other people
play a game
because they're what white people are
watching black well i guess what to do
uh nba players if they're so against
white supremacy would they want to be
unemployed they do i think that would be
better than being on the plantation like
colin kaepernick said about the nfl yeah
the slavery for the nba yeah well the
whole idea that they're contractually
obligated i think there's probably one
or two white guys left in basketball i
think there's an asian he's real tall
yeah and uh but
also like think about the the money that
creates for people who work for
companies that sponsor it even the
vendors that work there the people that
have to clean the bathrooms the people
who take care of parking there's all
kind of kinds of things that have to
keep the world turning yeah it's
completely unfair to just all of a
sudden stop that take away those jobs
from all those people and then blame it
on white supremacy just so you can just
completely gaslight the rest of the kind
of it also just doesn't make any sense
to just unemploy a bunch of black people
that's where who probably the area where
they have the highest median income on
earth exactly it makes no sense by the
way little known fact uh larry bird was
in fact kidnapped on the mediterranean
coast and he was victim to the north
african slave trade that's why he's so
good now
let's get this good let's get to some of
their claims here here's a claim that
they make
okay
that more gun control would have
prevented this shooting this is one of
the claims that they're making right now
so msnbc uh the political commentator
and former uh obama undersecretary of
state uh richard stengel stengel stangel
i always forget the name bengal he was
he was he was under uh obama as the
secretary of state okay tweeted this the
flaw in the system is
is not what's illegal but what's legal
that an 18 year old any 18 year old can
legally buy a military style assault
weapon hashtag gun control now now
that's the claim here's the truth
that is a lie
so new york already has very strict gun
control let me rattle these off for you
so i understand you understand according
to gifford's law which by the way not a
conservative source reference is
available at loudoscutter.com uh it's
the giffords law center for new york is
what it is they have different states um
new york has the sixth strongest gun
laws in the country okay six strongest
gun laws in the country
let me hit you with another truth here
that you probably should know the
shooter's gun was already illegal in new
york
ah he modified a bushmaster uh xm15es
uh illegally which is very easy for
anybody to do which makes it an assault
weapon according to new york law so uh
it's already illegal it's already
impossible to get he bought a firearm
and he modified it in a place that has
some of the strictest gun laws in the
country also here's a really important
truth that i think you need to know
we've talked about this in the past that
over 90 depending on the estimate
anywhere from 90 to 97 percent let's
call it an even 90 percent of mass
shootings occur where gun free zones now
that's the empirical the anecdotal is
this shooter specifically chose this
location because
of the strict gun laws this is what he
wrote plus new york has heavy gun laws
so it would ease me if i knew that any
legally armed civilian was limited to a
10 round magazine or cucked
firearms which brings us to another we
about to say it was just about to say i
don't understand why they they go
directly to nobody should have this
military-style assault weapon we've
talked about this before several times
nobody can define that term nobody it's
not a real term no that's what i'm
saying like it's like hate speech it's
like okay we'll define it nobody can
define it and so you're trying to say
that nobody should have the right to buy
any firearm that we don't like well
here's what they're trying that's
effective here's what they do assault
rifle is a term assault rifle is a
military term that usually refers to a
rifle with burst fire mode right the
ability selector switch now i'm just
kind of giving you a layman term here
there's more to it than that but assault
rifle is an actual term that's defined
and it's actually used as a descriptor
in the military yeah assault weapon is
something they expanded upon to trick
you to go oh we're talking about folio
no we're not no no we're not by the way
i'm carrying
an assault weapon
and there are many assault weapons in
the studio at any given moment
you can assault anybody with almost
anything but i mean in new york this gun
this handgun this walther is an assault
weapon yeah this would be illegal in new
york it's a very very common gun it's
just a little more badass because it's
customized
now this brings us to the next claim of
course that they will make that there's
a dragon on it yes
it's like nicholas cage and faceoff can
you do that for me i want the caster
troy now they'll say it's the magazine
we need to ban high-capacity assault
weapon
magazines and this is what they try and
do they try and make it look like rifles
with these high-capacity magazines are
responsible for most shootings uh here's
a quote from democrat and chronicle it
says large magazines or those containing
more than 10 rounds played a role in at
least 86 mass shootings since 1980. well
why did they pick 1980 why did they pick
that number well let me hit you with a
truth
handguns are actually responsible for
the vast majority of shooting deaths i
know what some of you are going to say
liberals are watching this going we need
to ban handguns most reasonable
americans are saying well we can't just
ban all handguns yeah
so i know that i'm giving ammo to those
who want to ban all guns like the beta
o'rourke
i don't think most americans want this
to be illegal so in 2020 united states
uh handguns accounted for 59 percent of
all murders
long barrel weapons something like
rifles
uh shotguns depending on which one
you're talking about three percent of
all murders is that what you're doing
you're doing the mathematical one well
i'm saying is that that's 62 that's
because all murders not just gun
homicides but of all murders only three
percent
are committed using long guns like
rifles
wow
and out of 40 uh sorry out of 400
million guns in the united states only
20 million are assault weapons and
that's also a stat i just look grain of
salt because it's not really easily
defined i'm just using the stats that
are available to us i'm just letting you
know that that stat is kind of [ __ ]
it's the best one i could come up with
yeah am i fair it's the best terrible
stat that we could find yes in fact this
is one of those things that people talk
about ten round magazines now for
example my uh when my brother lived in
california he was limited to certain
magazines look let me let me let me show
you guys something okay here so i'll
take this out just so everyone check
this beforehand so yeah we see right
alec baldwin just so you guys are clear
okay
where's the least liked person in the
studio yeah
so again just just showing you guys so
you everyone can see here make sure that
they see this is unloaded so this is in
fact uh this is a 17-round magazine okay
that's true just a standard handgun it's
not really all that big or scary but
let's say it's 10 rounds
okay click click click click click click
click i didn't count 10 but let's
imagine account 10 click click click
click bang
now it's 20 rounds that fast that fast
it's a good reason it's pretty easy
it does it doesn't make any sense like
their argument is he just wanted to brag
he has he has some skills there he does
the argument is that okay if we just
limit the broker's magazine by the way i
don't want around with it earlier wall
through i need you to send me another
one go ahead it was not throw it in the
trash outside of an elementary school
uh where do i have room for my crack
pipe that's true
no i mean this is the same argument that
we get frustrated about every single
time right it's it you've got to blame
something other than evil people right
you've got to point to something and
they're pointing to magazine capacity
right now right they're pointing which i
just proved is like okay fine you you
want you want to split second right
difference yeah well and here's the
thing
and i understand that it'll be hard to
do a reload under stress which is why
it's important here's the thing it's
more important for the average civilian
the average homeowner to have a higher
capacity magazine than it is for someone
who's a mass shooter or someone who's
experienced because somebody who isn't
used to being under stress is probably
going to have a tougher time with a
reload than someone who is a serial home
invader which brings us to another claim
right here that they're about to make
and they say that nobody needs ah
an assault weapon and this is not even a
new one but here you go now
i know this has been a hobby horse of
mine for a long time
got it done once
we should also ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines in this country
for that ten years we had it done
yeah that worked like a church mass
shootings actually went down
and they still went down after yeah
even law enforcement officials
have told me and told other
champions of this legislation they
sometimes feel outgunned
by assault weapons with large capacity
magazines let's come back to that
there's no reason someone needs a weapon
of war with 100 rounds 100 bullets
that can be fired
from that weapon by the way it doesn't
make it doesn't make sense like how is
this a visual of bullets he was
picturing uh a 12 year old's ass and no
one needs
that kind of a mag no one needs those
kinds of weapons we'll tell that to the
people of shanghai
that's science don't worry yeah it's
okay yeah yeah it's just doctors from
beating the [ __ ] out of you yeah
it's the director's cut of the final
scene from e.t oh here you go
here's johnny
[Laughter]
i wish she had a gun yeah yeah are you
saying that you wish she shot him
correct
correct just like i wish that every
single woman who's being forcibly raped
could shoot their attacker because i
want to read those headlines not
defenseless victim left in a ditch and
the only thing that makes a woman
stronger than a man is a gun keep in
mind the left also celebrated ukrainian
citizens taking up arms to defend their
country right we also sent something 40
or 900 billion dollars i don't know what
the number is it's a rounding error at
this point but this is something else uh
biden is is so incapable so
you know i always say the references are
available at lightercredit.com i don't
read conservative sources if you look at
like the last sources let me even look
here this is uh new york times right the
last source before that was pew research
and abc and before that was democrat and
chronicle so we make these publicly
available and i do that because i don't
really have an interest in in people who
are just preaching to the choir and it's
not lost on me that you know about 65
percent of you are conservative we have
a significant amount of people who
aren't conservative or don't identify as
conservative but it's of no value for me
to address these myths and just point
you to conservative or pro-gun sites
that use the same arguments and they
don't really have to defend them nearly
as
as strongly
so i
i am one thing i'm decent
doing is
knowing where they're about to go before
they go there joe biden right there we
said now police
come on they're telling me they've been
out gunned no
i know exactly what he was referring to
this is when police largely changed over
from service revolvers i don't remember
the year but i believe it was a shootout
in miami when the police were out gunned
uh with gang members and that's when
they changed over to revolvers changed
from revolvers over to semi-automatic
weapons now keep in mind these are
police officers and the revolvers were
typically six shots some of them had
seven shots i know this because i have
one of those revolvers i have a smith
wesson 581 which was developed to be the
ultimate police revolver and it actually
is unfortunately just came in at the
wrong time when they started switching
to semi-automatic weapons i know exactly
what he was referring to it's not a cop
who told him that because cops have been
using semi-automatic handguns for the
last several decades but that is the
reason that they switched over and by
the way it wasn't that they were
outgunned because the other guys had
semi-automatic handguns it's that they
were outgunned period because they only
had six shots in their revolvers and
reloading was a problem keep in mind
home invasions don't typically occur
with one person
if you're in the house there's a
difference between someone breaking and
entering and a home invasion when you
are there yeah let's say two people
break in let's say it's three people and
i love revolvers you've got six shots
in the dark and a shaky hand
be nice to have 17
or be nice to have a rifle with 25 40.
and you know who it's you know who it's
nicest for
a woman
or someone who has no chance against the
absolute monsters who are breaking into
that house knowing that people are home
and are willing to commit violence
firearms protect the most vulnerable
among us okay
let's go shoot out the one where they
had the body armor too i think that was
la right that was l.a
i wasn't sure it was the same yeah that
was that was different but that was
another one where yeah i think they
well they had well that was armor and
and weapon weapons yeah and they said
let's uh let's ban let's ban people
having the ability to defend themselves
from bullets oh
so that's a perfect example people say
criminals use guns let's ban guns and
you have some people who are dumb enough
to say okay and they go hey criminals
use defensive tools that keep them from
being killed let's ban that from it for
everybody well just because you banned
us doesn't mean the criminal can't get
it that's the part i don't understand
but it's also the silliest thing in the
world it's it's something that couldn't
possibly cause harm
people don't have the right to have a
bulletproof vest yeah well let me let me
just dave what you just said is exactly
right so new york right now what they're
trying to do is get the states around
them they're blaming the other states
for this problem we already have laws in
place we're very strong of course that's
what's big laws we're blaming the other
states because that's where this stuff
is coming from and chicago blames
indiana of course yeah so now we have to
expand so that only ends if the entire
country follows the strictest gun laws
that any one state has yes that's it
that's where it goes so don't think oh
this is their problem this is california
this is connecticut this is chicago's
issue with illinois this is what they
want for everyone because that's the
only way in their minds that it works
and guess what it still doesn't work no
it's true though because canada unless
they do it and it's a really tough
argument to make but i understand the
case they're making that manhattan is a
cesspool of filth and sadness because of
those uh those people coming in from
westchester and those amish animal
animals coming in from lancaster
pennsylvania oh that's really what's
ruining manhattan exactly it's great
that you can't defend yourself with
weapons in manhattan because nothing
dangerous ever ever no no no oh there's
no guns guys in manhattan do you know
this right there's no gun no i know no
i'm none no berry a gun to be found i've
never been woken up to the sound of
gunfire criminals throw rocks at each
other because they have no weapons no
that's crack rocks and that's how it's
different yeah he throws it in the trash
outside the grade school
now here's another can get a gun though
if you're a criminal yeah well it's very
easy very easy very easy
plenty of them have guns
here's another claim
that they're going to make and they're
making that gun violence right now so
they want to combine gun control and
then tell you that gun violence is a
problem of what it's a white supremacy
now i'm sure you probably know that this
does not hold water
let me ask you comment below
does that pass a sniff test for anyone i
would particularly like to hear from uh
you know black people watching right now
do you really believe that gun violence
is a white supremacy problem you know
some stats are coming but don't be
embarrassed i just want to know if you
buy it because here's the truth
black people kill white people at a much
higher rate than white people kill black
people they also kill black people at a
higher rate
than white people kill black people so
let's look at the murder uh by race of
offender and the victim from 2019 these
are the most recent stats we could find
from the fbi fbi
white people killed 246 black americans
black people killed 566
white uh americans keep in mind
the population difference that means
that white people killed less than half
the amount of blacks when they make up
76 percent of the population but black
americans killed double the amounts of
lights even though they only make up
about 13 percent of the population
that is an unbelievable gap so if i have
to watch another film
where the where the bully is the college
is the white kid in the letterman jacket
or the person breaking in for some home
security system commercial is the white
guy with a bolo tie i'm going to lose it
but stephen it's still white supremacy
sorry yeah it's so menacing society boys
in the hood jersey drive you know there
were some movies that kind of captured
yes
reality but that was of course 30 years
ago and who could forget john cougar
mellencamp's famous hit click click boom
yep
[Laughter]
huey huey lewis and the glocks he
doesn't know oh yeah totally we've been
glorifying us for a very long time yeah
and the blood-soaked news and this is
the thing they want they want white
americans to feel uh guilty yeah if for
example after the knockout game and
after you see these this unbelievable
wave of crime that had taken place uh
over the pandemic the riots they want
you to feel guilty can we've talked we
talked about this yesterday this is
this is the overarching theme here they
want you to feel guilty for saying oh
you know what i get a little bit nervous
as a white woman in a primarily black
neighborhood uh where i i'm my head is
on a swivel oh why is that well because
you know i'm exponentially more likely
to be shot raped or robbed
don't say that
but they encourage black people to live
in fear of the white supremacy that
statistically is a non-factor right
because every single one of the
community leaders has been out there
saying the al sharptons and everybody
saying
white people white supremacy racism
that's the problem that you have to be
afraid of and so if you're a black
person and that's the only voice that
you're hearing right now you believe it
and you go white people are out to get
me yeah and so now an entire community
fears something that they shouldn't and
these communities can no longer hang out
i don't think most black people actually
i don't think they do either but i'm
saying if that's the only voice your
your community is hearing which a lot of
times it is come on yeah a lot of times
you're hearing this is white supremacy
white supremacy that's the problem going
on in america right now it's white
supremacy they're saying it right now
the most the greatest threat in this
country right now is white supremacy
right right either is the biggest
domestic threat even though we're headed
towards what seems like another summer
of love coming our way with riots and
protests well love and rape are used you
know interchangeably that's true well
either side coming at you like that
creates a gigantic amount of anxiety
which has already been created over the
last two and a half years the i'm not
surprised these things are happening at
the rate that they are because of what's
been going on right it's all anxiety
bubbling to the surface but i th here's
the bit what i would say is a big
difference though and i agree with you
the difference is the anxiety that's
created one way for example if
white americans
feel concerned if they're in a primarily
black neighborhood particularly after
2020 the anxiety is statistic induced
the anxiety that's being induced in the
black community is from leadership lying
that's the problem
is look i think that if if if you're if
you're a white person at a black lives
matter riot whether it's baltimore you
know ferguson whether it's going on in
dallas whether
yeah i i think you'd be a fool to not be
concerned now that does not mean every
interaction with bl i've said that my
interactions you know we do the talking
with people are far more pleasant with
the average black american than with the
average you know american white [ __ ]
now here's the thing
i don't think there is a single group of
people in the history of this country
who have been more overly represented in
media and the entertainment industry
while simultaneously having no accurate
representation than black people what do
i mean by that you think this white you
think this speaker you think this press
secretary is representative of the
average black american you think al
sharpton is you think what you're seeing
on hbo is it's not even close go and
talk with them go and talk with them
but they they make up a huge percent
black americans make up a huge percent
of what we see in media but it is not
emblematic of black american voices
primarily
they grow up in christian households
primarily they tend to be family-centric
primarily they tend to be socially
conservative and yes there are issues
that the black community obviously
struggles with that they need to deal
with themselves i can't offer solutions
because i'm a white guy but we're not
offering mass shootings of black people
that's just a statistical inaccuracy and
that's that's the problem with sowing
division based on a lie and telling
people to shut up about the truth
truth is white people are being often
record numbers by black people in this
country when you look at the crime
between races same thing applies with
asians and crimes being committed
against them by black people
these are not these people coming in
these crimes are not people who are
afraid of white supremacy or asian
supremacy that's a statistical reality
and so yes you have a lot of white
people who are afraid
and so they're less likely to reach
across the aisle and speak with people
in these communities
but when you acknowledge a statistical
reality if we're going to address the
problem we need to stop silencing people
from speaking of the truth
and when you stop lying to one group of
people to try and so dis trying so uh
you know chaos let's uh let's go to
another claim that they will make here i
think we're up to claim number five uh
and they say now that censoring social
media is what's necessary because that's
what causes
shootings meanwhile new scrutiny and
criticism of social media tonight as
powerful fallout begins in the wake of
that gun massacre it wasn't just a live
streaming of the murders that the
accused killer posted while the carnage
happened
it's also the wide open social media
sites rife with racism and hatred pushed
by white supremacists how to deal with
all this
it seems simple
but it is complicated as a first
amendment scholar i have to reinforce it
we don't have first amendment guarantees
to
social media hate that amounts to
violence and harming people and taking
the lives of people
that's not a question of speech that's a
conduct that we deem to be illegal
look this is what they do they start
with a little kernel of
truth
they serve a little kernel of something
that's true where they say well yeah
look of course no one's saying that
people have the right to twitch stream
shootings dummy
but then someone like this and then the
governor of new york not fringe people
say this is why we need to clamp down on
on social media
okay here's the truth
that's a really stupid thing to say you
and tipper gore right remember with
bowling for when not bowling for
columbus with the columbine shooting
they blamed the the matrix they blamed
natural-born killers they blamed the
video game doom and now they're blaming
social media and i understand what
they're saying they're trying to say
people now are using social media to get
famous oh okay so social media business
hey hold on a second do you bear any
responsibility
media hey you know what let me point you
to an example let's bring up cnn right
now if someone is committing a mass
shooting because they want to become
famous you haven't done anything to
encourage that have you cnn
timothy mcveigh columbine shooters
right abc nbc uh cbs you guys have never
given air time to mass shooters brought
up in 99
of all movies that involve mass
shootings because we all know it's the
media that pushes their name out there
exactly and it gives them the glory that
they want so now they want to blame
whether it's twitch or whether it's
twitter whether it's youtube face who by
the way remove these as soon as they go
up
they're removed everywhere on social
media
but not from traditional media not from
legacy media these dinosaurs that are
dying they're the ones giving it air
time they're the ones making these
people famous and they want to say that
the responsibility lies with you
for tweeting out cdc statistics or
skepticism of the pfizer vaccine so now
we need the ministry of truth to claim
that's the problem the problem is the
problem is people have guns in new york
people uh uh people are racist white
supremacy and uh people are people if
this is so this is a social media
problem ah yeah it's hate speech again
right it's it's something that's very
very very hateful yeah when the truth is
people don't have enough guns right and
the truth is that uh media has
encouraged this media is what has made
people famous and the truth is the
statistical discrepancy between white
and black crimes is something that has
not been addressed and so it's festering
beneath the surface because people know
the truth and you're lying to them
that's the truth yeah no
the black and the white woman hugging
right there is an example of what's
wrong with the media they immediately go
to division that's the worst possible
thing you can do in these situations it
just creates more of this and it took
them a second to build that narrative
right well here's here's the thing that
i'm i'm hoping doesn't happen but i know
that it always will so there is a
consequence to this right when
politicians run to these things and they
start pushing a boogeyman just like they
were saying cops are out to kill black
people well that ended up with officers
in dallas texas being shot and killed
specifically because this person wanted
retribution against cops that were out
to kill black that's anecdotal and the
empirical is a record number of police
casualties absolutely and so what we're
seeing right now is every single
politician on the left is running to
this issue and saying yes that's right
white supremacy and gun control and hate
speech guess what that's going to do
white people are out to get you black
people guess that what that's going to
do it's going to push black people to
say
i can't take this anymore i can't i've
got to do something about this and
hopefully that's not something and again
it's an evil person that's going to go
out and do something to get retribution
but there is a cost and politicians are
screwing around to get votes yeah that's
it that's all they want from this they
don't care about you if they did they
would define gun control laws that would
prevent these things from happening but
they can't they would define hate speech
but they can't it's just votes that's it
the good news is black people don't
watch cnn or msnbc well yes no and why
do they want those votes money right
power all money yeah absolutely well no
no didn't you just hear uh
madame jean-pierre she said no we're
going to take the money from the rich
people ah yes oh right right because
they're also screwing you so if you
watch cnn msnbc abc nbc cbs or listen to
any press release that comes from the
white house you would believe that your
country right now is a quagmire gas is
up inflation is up violent crime is up
mass shootings are up because of rich
white people ah and their tax bill by
the way i would just like to point out a
couple of years ago elon musk paid the
largest tax bill by any person in the
united states 11
billion dollars and he's
african-american he is then last
december you know what they said they
sent two years ago
all to the ukraine yeah and other
countries
thanks elon we appreciate that hey elon
you know what that uh 40 whatever is 41
a billion dollars to buy twitter you
could solve world hunger what's this a
40 billion to ukrainian house why aren't
you fixing the starving people
[Laughter]
i gave you i give you 11 billion to help
with that yeah it's not our job no it is
no literally uh you
i did one of those big checks
yeah
that would be hilarious a giant
cardboard check
and he would like create an actual
hologram of ed mcmahon because he could
to deliver it
i have a gilmore i came in second but i
want a big check
well give me one of those guys
so look you guys can uh comment which
which which gun myth gun control or mass
shooting myth do you think is the most
pervasive because we're going to be
doing an arc on this we want to talk
about this more we want to make sure
that you go into your college classrooms
that you go into your fam you go to your
family dinners and you are prepared to
address this to do it effectively i just
think that conservative media has failed
so many people i really do and this is
look this is this is primarily a comedy
show i'm honestly but we're very
straightforward about it that's also why
we make the references publicly
available that's also why occasionally
we just go onto the street and talk with
people so you can see what those
interactions are like i grew up in
canada for the most part didn't have fox
news we didn't have am radio and so my
opinions were formed basically from what
i could read and i got to see john
stossel segments on 2020 after tgif when
i came to the united states and i was
saying okay i want to learn how to be
able to defend my points of view and how
to express them and i saw the media
available i said are you
are you serious that wouldn't work
it's the political and cultural
equivalent of aikido it only works with
people who are willing you need to learn
how to engage with people who disagree
with you and that's what we're trying to
do this week so that never again will
one of these mass shootings occur and
you be caught flat-footed with these
arguments that have not changed since
the 1990s they've changed zero
okay well don't fall into it too right i
mean when you walk around and you say
something you know if you say something
horribly racist or you blame another
race or you do whatever it is remember
that's exactly what they want right they
want you to buy that they want you to be
afraid they want you to be afraid of the
other side they want you to be nervous
they want you to be anxious they want
you to be scared they want you to give
up everything including your rights
right and why you think the boogeyman is
robert byrd yeah real quick question for
our for our guys in the studio here not
in the studio but in the control room
they just announced that they've made an
arrest in the dallas shooting of a
korean-owned
hair salon
cnn just covered the entire story i
didn't hear any mention of rice but it
was a korean-owned salon and i'm just
curious if the race is known so you guys
look it up and see if the rest just
happened there was a shooting in a
korean salon uh it happened a couple of
days ago uh i don't know how many people
remember when one happened i don't
remember if it was in texas the guy
showed up the massage parlor and then it
was racially emotional
he went to the wrong slot for that it's
like yeah you got to go to the right
place
this was from an hour ago but the dallas
morning news says that the police
announced the arrest early tuesday but
did not provide the suspect's name so i
don't think we're going to get the race
okay yeah if they don't know
all right yeah well i'm just curious one
guess yep just curious now i i mean it
could be wrong spit before we go to uh
uh before we go to the project veritas
twitter which is fantastic by the way
i went to uh an asian when i lived in
new york city uh an asian massage parlor
for a long that i did they walk on later
i later thought um
i might have gone to a dirty massage
parlor and i didn't really but here's
the thing
i uh because i didn't know how this
worked they were just old ladies like 70
years old so i didn't think that's how
it worked but then i realized once i was
in the unbelievable massages but like
gross violation of towel laws but then i
realized that if they were a dirty
massage parlor i was using them
because i was just paying the standard
40 fee for massage and they were waiting
for a tip i'm like well see ya
you're left with a smile on your face
tables turned
could be i don't know i genuinely don't
know i thought it was a massage though
it was unbelievable it was always
unbelievable the back room like the
place was called the wax shack
spelled in chinese i don't know what it
said i don't know who it is i found out
afterwards thanks to the golden panda
delicious but there was one
seven-year-old lady she uh i went back
like the fourth time she was like i
never tell you this you are very
handsome i'm like that's weird but thank
you well i think it's just now please
touch my knife massage i just keep my
underwear on so i think that's the deal
yeah right like wherever you go i mean i
guess if you're like a massage envy and
you're just like naked there's just a
towel over every part but here yes
yes remember from massage
put on your saran wrap body suit with
the hole oh yeah yeah
yeah i think it's just that's the clue
of like nah i just seriously my neck
hurts i fly a lot yeah well that was
this place they had because they had a
front room where you could sit in the
chair where just they just did your neck
right yeah it wasn't a weird place i
mean there were no separate rooms well
then why do you think it was a dirty
thing well she rubbed my nipples
so let's go to twitter
money
she paid me money on request okay all
right that's nipples pink like a ice
cream cone very cute
that's a weird analogy but thank you oh
i mean i think anybody can be bought i
mean trust me
gerald's anybody's nope can be a sex
slave i could either write a match yeah
yeah pretty much except i also don't
think that male gigolos are a thing i
really don't no why would you no one
pays for that no why just go out just go
out and say
yes yeah
just [ __ ] go does anybody want to
yeah everyone yeah that was really
that's hard you could be the grossest
woman alive and you will still find a
guy who's just like okay yeah yeah
gigolo yeah why would anyone pay for it
you're just you know what the point is
fiscal responsibility all right
now let's move on to
this is another story uh that has uh
been breaking here and
hats off to project very tested a great
job yeah this twitter senior engineer
murugen i don't know if i'm pronouncing
it
pretty close
uh
was
this is possibly the most obvious
catfishing in history with project
veritas and then he goes on to say all
of the things that we've known to be
true but haven't entirely been able to
prove due to the obfuscation with the
algorithms but here's some of the
footage so do you think there's a
difference between twitter's definition
of free speech and elon's definition of
facebook
[Music]
taking the capitalists if we weren't
really operating the capital small we
were very social it's like we're all
like
communist for example
transgender
[Laughter]
just gotta tolerate it
and the left will be like no i'm not
gonna tolerate it
i need a
sensor
or else i'm not gonna be able to now so
this is a public service announcement
if you look and sound like that and a
girl is interested in you randomly who's
even like a six
you're being lied to
just ask cause he's in sorry
although he's trying to like that's him
trying to be bad yeah badass he's like
we're commie as [ __ ]
we're so i am so bad yes i support the
slaughter of a hundred million people
and star i'm i'm a stalinist oh i'm bad
boy
but i did not order the burger no
i mean i did but it's mushroom burger
but you know what the point is
i am bad
look at my sleeve i roll it up and put a
pack of cigarettes in this in the
t-shirt here like i'm like james dean
i'm commie those are candy
well then yes they're popeye cigarettes
but i look i'm a prudent bad boy
you're not very prudent because you just
said on camera that you only censor
conservatives oh is that the blinking
light oh yeah why did you keep adjusting
your lapel i thought it was a fashion
choice i thought good looking women were
wearing blinking lights in between their
titties
the first time i've been so close to
them yes
i don't deal with people well i thought
it was like an iron man thing that went
right there that you know powered your
sexiness i am bad i'm cut do you still
want to sleep with the commie no okay
i'm just going to be unemployed bad boy
oh yeah these guys totally get fired
pretty quickly elon may elon may keep
him because he says i you know i'm i'm
leaning more towards elon's kind of way
of thinking in the video oh i keep him
yeah he's a blinking dot on her forehead
go on just don't ever give interviews
again the prophecy is true
[Laughter]
yes talking to here
yeah
yeah prophecy
does not blink
how are these people still tricked i you
know
you give a guy you give a guy a little
bit of attention a little bit of alcohol
and all of a sudden he's just like yeah
i'll tell you everything you wanted to
know you just keep writing the answers
down which is kind of weird but i'll
keep talking yeah you don't even have to
torture men just something this good
looking woman and they'll be like yes
we're stupid i'll tell you what i do
yeah just that you give them the one
thing they can't resist right and you
know you have to give it to them you
just have to show up in front of them
and they'll think that you're giving it
to them because they're stupid yeah give
them
the idea that they might have a chance
yeah by the way if you don't think elon
musk can make this company a little bit
better this guy said he's been working
four hours a week but he's going to try
harder because he wants a promotion but
his job currently pays him around 190
000
yes i am like the reverse team ferris
yes yes yes yes they they do a great job
i mean i'm similar to tim ferriss only i
don't actually work
by the way do you know what happened
under real communism if you worked four
hours a week they killed you yes they
did yes it was because you're already
dead that's how much you people don't
understand this about communism that
communism was based on the fundamental
idea that the workers were working very
hard very very hard for very little yeah
but everybody had very little right yeah
everybody had very little except for the
upper upper upper tier and so you
weren't jealous of anybody else but you
could rat them out if they did something
wrong and they would be killed so maybe
do you get to keep their stuff was this
guy just using like the the handbook for
pickup lines in silicon valley did he
really think this was going to work
we censor conservatives i'm commie and i
am very unproductive do you want to have
sex with me now
a very lazy adult male
passive [ __ ]
i have six roommates but i better try
harder
i'll work five hours a week i have six
roommates
eight if you count the garage
but we have roosters yes the pet
roosters in silicon valley
i have a cat
so you know what good on you james
o'keefe good work i recommend you go to
project veritas check out the rest of it
um
everyone else has already provided
valuable commentary obviously we know i
mean we just saw a gain of i think i saw
a game personally 250 000 subscribers in
the last like
uh twitter followers in the last three
weeks you can follow me at s crowder you
can follow all of us you have atlandau
dave at g morgan jr and at s crowder uh
and all of a sudden now my tweets are
actually getting to you weird how that
happened it's bizarre it's crazy yeah i
i am actually they often refer to me as
the bad boy of twitter
they say there goes a bad boy on twitter
he doesn't wear a seat belt or sunscreen
dave is wearing my hat yes
i don't know what that means i don't
catch the reference but we're going to
do the transgender sleepover uh which we
cannot talk about on youtube so you too
piss off